ja ok
hallo mein name zigaretten hier kommen
heute zu einem neuen video im moment ist
gekommen an dem ein spiel rausgekommen
ist ob das nicht mal wieder so richtig
gefreut haben eben viel daneben dpa das
meinen lieblingen spieler aller zeiten
und war ist mit nadeln controller luca
[Musik]
in den player am start wir haben hier
mehrere optionen wie beispielsweise
lokales bio mein gott man kann zu zweit
gegeneinander spielen lokal leute
lassmann fetten like da und dann werde
ich mit maxi schönen paar mario kart
challenge wird machen wir können online
turnier machen wir können den
mehrspieler modus gehen oder wir können
einzelspieler machen und ich würde sagen
wir kriegen einfach mal auf
einzelspielern stützen und von bisschen
abenteuer ich habe bei baker spielen
noch kein einziges mal gespielt
also es wird jetzt ganz interessant
kollege was hast du dazu ok danke für
dein vertrauen ich habe jetzt einfach
mal auf grand prix gedrückt und jetzt
haben wir hier verschiedene
meisterklassen also beispielsweise 50
kubik ist relativ und 200 kubik
halsbrecherisch leute
eigentlich bin ich ja schon profi will
ich mir das gerade nur ein oder gibt es
hier enorm viele neue charaktere ich
weiß zum beispiel nicht werden mit linda
ist oder büro von animal crossing oder
dem trotzdem ganz casual einfach mal
mario ist immer noch mein kind heidfeld
als auto stellen wir uns einfach mal was
bodega alter mann hat ja mega viele
auswahlmöglichkeiten ich nehme einfach
mal einen rennwagen mit relativ rallye
reifen und dazu noch einen fallschirm
und dann würde ich sagen starten wir
direkt mit dem pils cup ich bin gespannt
meine damen und herren wir dinge schon
im laden spielt man die scheiße
eigentlich ein paar sekunden später also
angeblich gibt man auf a glass of the
toyota ist gab geben
l und erik es geht los bei muss man gas
gibt damit man irgendwie vom fleck
kommen aus deutschland alle überholt und
meine damen und herren wo kann ich
besser verdammte scheiße aber hier
erstmal weiter schön rumpelig lockemann
so malter das geht ja alles weh gab mir
warum soll weg und davor noch ein
absehbar ich komme mit überhaupt nicht
klar ich denke die ganze zeit die kräfte
auf das feld nebenan aber irgendwie dann
doch noch die kurve driften hier das
mitnehmen um die kranken unglücklichen
schön treibt noch mitnehmen hier einmal
rum und hier noch die leitung wird
einfach nicht wahr das ist ja nur noch
raus hier alles wie krieg nicht mehr
irgendwelche eignet wird anstatt ja auch
ein bisschen standard einer als erster
eine schöne münze ich bin schon wieder
zweiter aber cool ich bin dritter ich
bin da ja toll dirk ja noch in den rhein
ich bin fünfter nicht so dass mich auch
interessiert den coolen platz zu haben
drei bananen bringen auf jeden fall
richtig als item
ich bin auf jeden fall schon markiert
doch ein bisschen von mono vertrauten
genau jener vom staat wieder bananen
träumt weiter zweiter platz meine damen
und herren es war mein erstes mal mario
kart und ich wurde zweiter
[Musik]
einen wasserpark so ich bin wieder als
mario diesmal glaube ich sogar genau
hier an zweiter position weil ich am
letzten rennen zweiter wurde das häufig
gebe jetzt schon gar die anderen
natürlich schneller als ich war ja klar
für ein alter mitnehmen die erste kurve
habe ich jetzt nicht gut bekommen
eine banane hinter mir schmeißen hier
mitten in die kurve wieder brückenbauer
war da natürlich überholen unter wasser
die am altar mario kart er richtig heiß
geworden muss wirklich sagen dass es zu
beginn nicht so begeistert war von
nintendos wii-konsole weil einfach noch
nicht zu beginn waren einfach nicht so
viele spiele draußen mag das ja ich war
immer überall gegen wenn ich ihnen was
er zu sagen will
ich war zu beginn nicht so begeistert
von der sendung switch konsole weil
einfach noch keine wirklichen games
draußen waren die man irgendwie konnte
ich war zu beginn nicht so begeistert
von der konsole weil einfach noch nicht
so viele games draußen waren aber jetzt
gerade als mario kart wirklich raus
gekommen ist und wieder zugeschickt
bekommen haben
das macht einfach mehr spaß mich an
diese alten
nintendo zeiten wo man auf klassenfahrt
das ganze irgendwie gespielt hat dritter
diese rennen gehen mega schnell jetzt
mal eine andere frage gefällt euch das
wäre nicht ein bisschen mehr wieder
gaming auf meinem kanal bringe als jetzt
gerade mit mario kart max und ich uns
ein paar challenges überlegt oder auch
mit anderen spielen wie beispielsweise
einem brett oder so ich habe ein paar
neue games tut wenn in der bottroper
dann schreibt mario kart in die
kommentare
und das dritte von vier rennen meine
damen und herren schöngarth eben hier
und den power statt mit am start und ich
verstehe nicht wieso die alles schneller
findet ich weil ich habe genau den
gleichen power start und ich habe sogar
ein rennwagen eigentlich was ich
allerdings mit dem komisch finde ist
dass mit dem dürften weil man öffnet und
dann kommt zunächst in die kurven da hat
man immer angst dass man einfach die
kurve nicht pflicht aber das ist einfach
anders geworden als bei den früheren
mario diese war ich denke so langsam
nach vorne das ist einfach anders
geworden als bei den früheren mario
kaiser hat man nicht genau abschätzen
können wenn man irgendwie geprüft wird
ist wie man die kurve kriegt ob man die
kurve kriegt und jetzt ist das ganze ein
bisschen schwieriger geworden aber jetzt
alles klar
und ich werde selber abgeschossen
na klar
okay man ihr seid mixa lösen arschlöcher
ihr schul und die kurven driften
doppelte seite mit ihnen das nämlich
auch neu dass man jetzt über diese
doppelfunktionen sich teilweise zweitem
warum werde ich von ihm gesehen hat auch
eine neue funktion hat man mehrere items
bekommen kann das heißt man kann
beispielsweise okay okay ich bin kleiner
ich muss in diesem rennen hier wirklich
jetzt mal langsam ernster werden damit
ich noch ein paar chance und vielleicht
sogar auf dem kopf 3 podiumsplatz bei
diesem ganzen gelben orangen gedriftet
alle sachen mitgenommen hier das doppel
item ok und jetzt hier lang leute das
war eine sehr sehr gute fahrt gerade
freunde
oh mein gott leute ich bin erster ich
weiß nicht wo das viel ich weiß nicht wo
das ziel-s nein nein nein du wertvolle
mit
es ist immer so kurz vorm ende wird man
überholt ich bin das ganz knappe
trennten ich kann nur noch erster werden
wenn pietsch und anoki mario in den
nächsten rennen komplett verpacken also
ja wie weit man das nächste rennen
letzte friedel meine damen und herren
wieder vorne muss sich überholende
fingerte den da vorne ist ja warum hat
er so einen kranken staat immer wie kann
das sein und auch nicht aus wieder vor
mir und bauern drohen hier hoch meine
damen und herren hier mit dem gas geben
wir gas geben hier oben gas geben ihrer
tochter mitnehmen und hier den fall noch
weiter runter gefallen hier und hier
schon mal schönen hilft mitnehmen und
hier lang und das doppelte eigne ich
mich am start aber dafür habe ich sehen
komischen strähne hinterfragt also ich
muss sagen dass wir so eine biene froh
wenn man jetzt so sehr sehr krasse altem
aktionen gerade am start hat also wenn
man beispielsweise einen derart oder
einen pelz oder was das denn dem
oberrang kann ich wohl irgendwie
wegschmeißen dann kommt er wieder zurück
ich bin erster letzte runde meine damen
und herren ich muss auf jeden fall
vorsieht schon vor tagen mario hier
kommen damit ich irgendeine chance auf
den titel habe ja auch wieder schön die
seitenwänden mitnehmen damit ist
nochmals ein bisschen fuß kriege der
zweite platz ist auf jeden fall da jetzt
gerade bin ich sogar erster geworden
noch mal schön sondern mitnehmen und
jetzt hier dran vorbei so und jetzt habe
ich ihn mir und ihm nämlich am besten
ihr nein ich will die wiederholung davon
ich denke wenigstens ok werde vierter
und fünfter
also luca machen steht jetzt
wiederholung
befreien
david auf jeden fall die rangliste pete
wurde erst mit 50 punkten der anthologie
marion 48 mit 42 punkten platz drei wir
klicken mal einfach schauen uns die
ergebnisse an hob dabei wirklich sagen
ich bin sehr überzeugt von ihrem spiel
und meiner meinung nach das beste spiel
das in den letzten zwei drei jahren sich
irgendeine nintendo-konsole rausgekommen
ist neben pokémon weil die teile waren
eigentlich immer ganz cool fand halt
diesen typischen mario kart charakter
also dass man sich aufregt aber trotzdem
das spiel gegen die mark du hast 30
münzen gesammelt ein neues fahrrad
vorteile nun verfügbar ist blickt man
auf ok wenig die rangliste und gassen
müsste ist jetzt eigentlich schon
gewesen sein vom kap ja
wir befinden uns wieder im hauptmenü das
wartet auch schon ihr vom video meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat wie gesagt das gerne mal ein like da
ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr mario
kart in die kommentare schreiben
den max und ich dort wieder mit
vielleicht ein patient jetzt mal machen
sollen ihr findet nun hier oben ein
smiley eingeblendet wenn er darauf könnt
ihr einen kanal kostenlos abonnieren
deshalb hat keine videos mehrere
auffällig auch mein job eingeblendet in
dem am ersten wächst neue
sommerklamotten lounge werden und hier
unter anderem video verlinkt